The following content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR NELSON: All right,
well last time we finished our
sort of introduction to entropy
which is a difficult
topic, but I hope we got to the
point where we have some
working understanding of
physically what it's
representing for us, and
also an ability to
just calculate it.
So we went through at the end
of the last lecture, a few
examples where we just
calculated changes in entropy
for simple processes like
heating and cooling something
or going through a phase
transition where that process,
that sort of process is
relatively simple because
there's no temperature change.
While the ice is melting, for
example, you're putting heat
into it, but the temperature
is staying
at zero degree Celsius.
And we saw, how to do these
calculations, we need define
reversible paths.
So it was extremely
straightforward to calculate
the entropy of say ice melting
at zero degrees Celsius,
because there the process is
reversible, because that's the
melting temperature.
But if we wanted to calculate
the change in entropy of ice
melting, you know at, once it
had already been cooled to ten
degrees above the melting point,
to ten degrees Celsius,
then in order to find a
reversible path, we had to
say, OK, let's first cool it
down to zero degrees Celsius.
Then let's have it melt, and
then let's warm the liquid
back up to ten degrees Celsius
so we could construct the
sequence of reversible steps
that would get from the same
starting point to the same end
point, and we could calculate
the change in entropy through
that sort of sequence.
So now that we've got at least
some experience doing
calculations of delta S and
we're just thinking a little
bit about entropy, what I'd like
to do is to try to relate
the state variables together
in a useful way.
And and the immediate problem
that I'd like to address is
the fact that right now we
have kind of a cumbersome
expression for energy.
So you know we have u, we look
at du, right it's dq plus dw,
and you know, I don't
like those.
They're path specific, and it
would be nice to be able to do
a calculation of changes
in energy that
didn't depend on path.
You know it's a state
function.
So in principle it seems like it
sure ought to be possible,
and yet so far when we've
actually gone through
calculations of du, we've had
to go and consider the path
and get the heat and get
the work and so forth.
And then we found special cases,
you know an ideal gas
where the temperature, where the
change is only a function
of temperature and so forth,
where we could write this as a
function of state variables,
but nothing general that
really allows us to do the
calculation under all
circumstances.
So let's think about how
to make this better.
So, and what I mean by that is
you've seen examples like, you
know, some special examples
you saw awhile back.
The case where du was Cv dT
minus Cv and this Joule
coefficient d v. But you know
you still need to find those
coefficients for each system.
This isn't a general equation
that tells us how energy
changes in terms of only
functions of state.
Because of things like this and
this -- what I'd really
like is to be able to you know
write du equals something.
And that something, you know,
it can have T and p and
whatever else I need.
It can have S, H, and of course
differentials of any of
those quantities. dT or dp or
dS, dH, you name it, but all
state variables.
That's what I'd much
rather have.
And then, you know, if I want
to, if I've got something like
that and I want to find out how
the energy changes as a
function of volume, so I'll
calculate du/dV With respect
to some selected variable hold
constant, I can do it.
Right now, in a general sense,
that's cumbersome.
I've got to figure out how to
do that for each particular
case that I want to treat.
So, let's see how we could
construct such a thing.
Let's consider just a reversible
process, at
constant pressure.
So, OK, I've got one and I'm
going to in some path wind up
at state two and I'll write du
is dq, it's reversible in this
case, minus p dV.
And from the second law, we
know that we can write dq
reversible as T dS.
dq over T is dS or entropy.
So, we can write du is
T dS minus p dV.
That's so important, we'll
circle it with colored chalk.
That's how important it is.
You know it's a dramatic
moment.
So let's look at what
we have here.
Here's du and over on this side
we have T, we have S, we
have p and we have V. Suddenly
and simply, it's only
functions of state.
Well that was pretty easy.
So, what that's telling us is
that we can write u this way,
and you know, this is
generally true.
We got to this by considering
a reversible
constant pressure process.
But we know u is a state
variable right.
So this result is going to
be generally applicable.
And it tells us a couple
of things too.
It tells us that in some sense,
the natural variables
for u are these, right, it's a
function of S and V. Those are
natural variables in the sense
that then it written as
functions of those variables, we
only have state quantities
on the right-hand side.
Very, very valuable
expression.
And of course coming out of
that then, we can take
derivatives and at least for
those particular variables, we
can see that du/dS at constant
V is minus p.
And du/dV at constant
S is T. All right,
those fall right out.
Now we can have a similar set
of steps for H, for the
enthalpy, so let's just
look at that.
So H, of course, it's u plus
pV, so dH is just du plus
d(pV), and now there's our
expression for du.
We're going to use
it this way.
So it's T dS minus p dV
plus p dV plus V dp.
And of course these are
going to cancel.
So we can write dH is
T dS plus V dp.
Also important enough
that we'll
highlight it a little bit.
So again let's look at what
we've got on the right-hand
side here, T, S, V, p, only
quantities that are
functions of state.
And of course, we can take the
corresponding derivative, so
let's also be explicit here,
that means that were writing H
as a function of the
variables S and p.
And dH/dS at constant p is T,
and dH/dp at constant S is V.
So now we've got a couple of
really surprisingly simple
expressions that we can use to
describe u and H in terms of
only state variables.
All right?
We also can go from these
expressions, using the chain
rule, to expressions for
particularly useful
expressions for the entropy as
a function of temperature.
So, you know, from du
is T dS minus p dV.
We can rewrite this as
dS is one over T du
plus p over T dV.
And now we can go back, you
know, if we can go back to our
writing of u in terms of, as a
function of T and V, right.
So we can write here du as a
function of T and V, Cv dT
plus du/dV at constant T dV.
The reason we're doing that is
now we can rewrite dS is one
over T times Cv dT, and that's
the only temperature
dependence we're
going to have.
The other part is going to
be a function of volume.
So it's, we've got p over T plus
du/dV at constant T dV,
and what this says then is that
dS/dT at constant V is
just Cv over T. Very useful, not
surprising because of the
relation between heat at
constant volume and Cv, right.
And of course dS is just dq
reversible over T, but this is
telling us, in general, how
the entropy changes with
temperature at constant
volume.
We can go through the exact same
procedure with the H to
look at how entropy varies with
temperature at constant
pressure, and we'll get exactly
an analogous set of
steps that will be
Cp over T, right.
So also dS/dT at constant
pressure is Cp over T. OK?
Now I want to carry our
discussion a little bit
further and look at entropy a
little more carefully and in
particular, how it varies
with temperature.
And here's what I really
want to look at.
You know, we've talked about
when we look at changes in u
and changes in H, and we've
done this under lots of
circumstances at this point.
And at various times I've
emphasized, and I'm sure
Professor Bawendi did too, that
when we look at these
quantities we can only define
changes in them.
There's not an absolute scales
for energy or for enthalpy.
We can set the zero in
a particular problem,
arbitrarily.
And so, for example, when we
talked about thermochemistry,
we defined heats of formation,
and then we said, well, the
heat of formation of an element
in its natural state
at room temperature and pressure
we'll call zero.
We called it zero.
If we wanted to put some number
on it, and put energy
in it, we could have
done that.
We defined the zero.
So far, that's, well not just so
far, that's always the way
it will be for quantities like
energy and enthalpy.
Entropy is different.
So let's just see
how that works.
So, let's consider the entropy,
we'll consider as a
function of temperature
and pressure.
First let's just see how it
varies with pressure.
We're going to see -- what
we'll do is consider its
variation to both pressure and
temperature, and the objective
is to say all right, if I've
got some substance at any
arbitrary temperature and
pressure, can I define and
calculate an absolute number
for the entropy?
Not just a change in entropy,
unlike the cases with delta u
and delta H, but an absolute
number that says in absolute
terms the entropy of this
substance at room temperature
and pressure or whatever
temperature and pressure is
this amount.
Something that I can do by
choice of a zero for energy or
for u or H, but here,
I want to look
for an absolute answer.
All right, so let's start by
looking at the pressure
dependence.
So we're going to start with du
is T dS minus p dV, so dS
is du plus p dV over T.
Now let's look, T
being constant.
OK, and now let's specify
a little bit.
I want to make it something
as tractable as possible.
Let's go to an ideal gas.
So then at constant temperature,
that says du is
equal to zero.
So dS at constant temperature
is just p over T dV.
And in the case of an ideal
gas, that's nR dV over V.
And at constant temperature,
that means that d(nRT), which
is the same as d(pV) is equal
to zero, but this
is p dV plus V dp.
So this says that dV over V,
that I've got there, is the
same thing as negative
dp over p.
Right, so I can write that dS
as constant temperature is
minus nR dp over p.
So that's great.
That says now if I know the
entropy at some particular
pressure, I can calculate how
it changes as a function of
pressure, right.
If I know S at some standard
pressure that we can define,
then S at some arbitrary
pressure, is just S of p
naught and T minus the integral
from p naught to p of
nR dp over p.
All right, which is to say it's
S of p naught T minus nR
log of p over p naught.
Right, now normally we'll
define p naught as
equal to one bar.
And often you'll see this simply
written as nR log p.
I don't particularly like to
do that because of course,
then, formally speaking were
looking at something that's
written that has units inside
as the argument of a log.
Of course it's understood when
you see that, and you're
likely to see it in various
places, it's understood when
you see that the quantity p is
always supposed to be divided
by one bar, and the units
then are taken care of.
For one mole, we can write the
molar quantities S of p and T,
is S, S naught of T minus
R log p over p naught.
All right, so that's our
pressure dependence.
What about that?
We still don't really have a
formulation for calculating
this, or you know, defining it
or whatever we're going to do
to allow us to know it.
Well, let's just consider the
entropy as a function of
temperature, starting all the
way down at zero degrees
Kelvin, and going up to whatever
temperature we want
to consider.
Now, we certainly do know how
to calculate delta S for all
that because we've seen how to
calculate delta S if you just
heat something up, and we've
seen how to calculate delta S
when something under goes a
phase transition, right.
Presumably, if we're starting at
zero Kelvin, we're starting
in a solid state.
As we heat it up, depending on
the material, it may melt at
some temperature.
If we keep keep heating it
up, it'll boil at some
temperature, but we know how to
treat all of that, right.
So let's just consider something
that undergoes that
set of changes.
So, we've got some substance
A, solid, zero
degrees Kelvin, one bar.
Here's process one.
It goes to A, it's a solid
at the melting
temperature and one bar.
Process two is it turns into
a liquid at the melting
temperature and one bar.
Process three is we heat it up
some more, up to the boiling
temperature at one bar.
Process four is it evaporates,
so now it's a gas at the
boiling temperature
and one bar.
Finally, we heat it up some
more, so now it's a gas at
temperature T and one bar.
And if we wanted to,
we can go further.
We can make it a gas at
temperature and whatever
pressure we want.
That part we already know how
to take care of, right.
Well, let's look at what happens
to S, all right.
S, a molar enthalpy at T and
p, where we're going to
finally end up, is, well it's s
zero at zero Kelvin and one
bar or one bar is implied by
the superscripts here.
And then we have delta S for
step one, and delta S for step
two and so on.
So all right, let's, we can
label this six so we to all
the way to delta
S for step six.
Well, so we can do that.
It's S of the material at T
and p is S naught at zero
Kelvin, plus, here's
for process one.
We heat it up from zero Kelvin
up to the melting point.
Cp of the solid more heat
capacity, divided by T dT.
We can calculate delta S for
heating something up, right.
Plus, now we've got the heat of
fusion to melt the stuff,
so it's just delta H naught of
fusion, divided by Tm right.
We saw that last time.
In other words, remember,
we're just looking at q
reversible over T to get delta
S, and it's just given by the
heat of fusion.
All right, then let's go from
the melting point to the
boiling point.
So it's Cp now it's the heat
capacity, the molar heat
capacity of the liquid,
divided by T dT.
We're heating up the liquid.
And then there's vaporization.
Delta H of vaporization over
T at the boiling point.
Then we can go from the boiling
point to our final
temperature T. Now it's the
molar heat capacity of the gas
over T dT minus R log
p over p naught.
OK, so that's everything, and
these are all things that we
know how to do.
Just about.
OK, this one we're going to have
to think about, but all
the changes we know how
to calculate, right.
So if we plot this, S, and
let's just do this as a
function of temperature.
I don't have pressure
in here explicitly.
Well, it's going to change as
I warm up the solid, soon
we're really starting
at zero Kelvin.
This stuff is all positive,
right, so the change in
entropy is going
to be positive.
Entropy is going to increase
as this happens, and then
there's a change right at some
fixed temperature as the
material melts.
So here is step one.
Here is step two, right, this
must be the melting
temperature.
And then there's another
heating step.
Well, strictly speaking, I'm
going to run out of space here
if I'm not careful, so I'm
going to be a little more
careful here.
One, two, three.
I'm heating it up
a little more.
Entropy is still increasing,
right.
So I've done this.
I've done this.
Now I've heated up the liquid.
Now, I'm going to boil the
liquid, so it's going to have
some change in entropy.
This must be my boiling point,
and now there's some further
change in the gas, and that gets
me to whatever my final
temperature is, right, that
I'm going to reach.
Four and five, great.
So there is monotonic increase
in the entropy.
OK, so we're there, except
for this value.
That one stinking
little number --
S naught at zero Kelvin.
That's the only thing we
don't know so far.
So, for this we need some
additional input.
We got some input of the
sort that we need
in 1905 from Nernst.
Nernst deduced that as you go
down from zero Kelvin for any
process, the change in entropy
gets smaller and smaller.
It approaches zero.
Now, that actually was certainly
an important
advance, but it was superseded
by such an important advance
that I'm not even going to
reward it by placing it on the
blackboard.
Forget highlight, color,
forget it.
Because Planck, six years later,
in 1911, deduced a
stronger statement which
is extremely useful,
and it's the following.
What he showed is that as
temperature approaches zero
Kelvin, for a pure
substance in it's
crystalline state, S is zero.
A much stronger statement,
right.
A stronger statement than the
idea that changes in S get
very small as you approach
zero Kelvin.
No, he's saying we can make a
statement about that absolute
number S goes to zero as
temperature goes to zero.
For a pure substance in it's
crystalline state.
So that is monumentally
important.
So as T goes to zero Kelvin, S
goes to zero, for every pure
substance in its, and I'll
sort of interject here,
perfect crystalline state.
That's really an
amazing result.
So what it's saying is I'm
down at zero Kelvin.
Minimally, I've somehow cooled
it as much as I possibly
could, and I've got my perfect
crystal lattice.
It could be an atomic crystal
like this, or, you know, it
could be molecules.
But they're all exactly where
they belong in their locations
in the crystal, and the absolute
entropy is something
I can define and it's zero.
So S equals zero.
Perfect, pure crystal,
all right.
OK, well this came out of a
microscopic description of
entropy that I briefly alluded
to last lecture, and again
we'll go into in more detail
in a few lectures hence.
But the result that I mentioned,
the general result,
was that S was R over Na
Avogadro's number, times the
log of this omega number of
microscopic states available
to the system that
I'm considering.
Now normally for a macroscopic
system, I've got just an
astronomical number of
microscopic states.
You know, that could mean in
a liquid, different little
configurations of the molecules
around each other.
They're all different states.
Huge amounts of possible states,
and the gas even more.
But if I go to zero Kelvin,
and I've got a perfect
crystal, every atom,
every molecule is
exactly in its place.
How many possible different
states is that?
It's one.
There aren't any more
possible states.
I've localized every identical
lateral molecule in its
particular place,
and it's done.
And you know, if I start
worrying about the various
things that would matter under
ordinary conditions, right,
you know, maybe at higher
temperature, I'd have some
molecules in excited
vibration levels or
maybe electronic levels.
Maybe if it's hydrogen,
maybe everything isn't
in the ground state.
It's not all in the 1s orbital
but in higher levels.
Then there's be lots of states
available, right, even of only
one atom in the whole crystal
is excited, well there's one
state that would have
it be this atom.
A different one would have it
be this atom, and so forth.
Already, there'd be an enormous
number of states, but
at zero Kelvin, there's no
thermal lexitation of any of
that stuff.
Things are in the lowest states,
and they're in their
proper positions.
There's only one state for the
whole system, so that's why
the entropy is zero in
a perfect crystal.
At zero degrees Kelvin.
Now, there are things that may
appear to violate that.
Now of course you can make
measurements of entropy,
right, so it can be verified
that this is the case.
There are some things
that would appear to
violate that result.
You know, you can make
measurements of entropies, and
for example let's take carbon
monoxide crystal, CO.
So let's say this is
a crystal lattice,
it's diatomic molecules.
It's carbon oxygen carbon
oxygen carbon oxygen.
All there in perfect place
in the crystal lattice.
Well it turns out when you form
the crystal every now and
then -- you know, let's
put it in color.
Let's put it in the color that
we'll use to signify something
in some way evil.
No insult to people who
like that color.
I kind of like it in fact.
OK, so you know, you're making
the crystal, cooling it,
started out maybe in the gas
phase, start cooling it,
starts crystallizing.
Gets colder and colder, but you
know, carbon monoxide is
pretty easy for those things
to flip sides.
And even in the crystalline
state, even though it's a
crystal, so the molecules center
of mass are all where
they belong, still at ordinary
temperatures they will be able
to rotate a bit.
So even in the crystalline
state, when it's originally
formed, not at zero Kelvin,
there's thermal energy around.
These things can to get knocked
around, and the
orientations can change.
Now you start cooling it, and
you know, by and large they'll
all go into the proper
orientation.
Right, that's the lowest energy
state, but you know,
there are all sorts of kinetic
things involved.
There it takes time for the
flipping, depending on how
long, how slowly it was
cooled, and so forth.
May never happen, and then it's
cooled, and then anything
that's left in the
other orientation
is frozen in there.
There's no thermal
energy anymore.
It can't find a way
to reorient.
That's it.
All right, let's say we're down
to zero Kelvin, and out
of the whole crystal, we've
got a mole of molecules.
One of them is in the
wrong orientation.
Now how many states do
we have like that
that would be possible?
We'd have a mole of
states, right.
It could be this one.
It could be that one, right.
Or in general, of course
really there's a whole
distribution of them, and they
could be anywhere, and pairs
of them could be, and it doesn't
take long to get to
really large numbers.
So the entropy won't be zero.
Entropy of a perfect
crystal would mean
it's perfectly ordered.
So that's zero.
But things like that not
withstanding, and of course
it's the same if you have
a mixed crystal.
In a sense I've described a
mixed crystal where the
mixture is a mixture of carbon
monoxide pointing this way,
and carbon monoxide
pointing this way.
But a real mixed crystal with
two different constituents,
well of course, then you
have all the possible
configurations where, you know,
they could be here and
here and here, and then you
could move one of them around
and so forth, there
are zillions
and zillions of states.
But for a pure crystal, in
perfect form, you really have
only one configuration,
and your entropy
is therefore zero.
OK, so now, we can go back
and we can do this.
And at least in principle, even
for things that don't
form perfect crystals, we could
calculate the change in
entropy going from the perfect
ordered crystal to something
else with some degree of
disorder and keep going and
change the temperature and
do all these things.
So the real point is that this
is extremely powerful because
given this, we really can
calculate absolute numbers for
the entropies of substances, at
ordinary, not just at zero
Kelvin, but using this which,
you know, this is a really
very straightforward
procedure.
And in fact these things are
really quite easy to measure.
You know, you do calorimetry,
you can measure those delta H
of fusions, right, delta
H of vaporization.
You can measure the heat
capacities, the things in the
calorimeter.
You'll see how much heat
is needed to raise the
temperature a degree.
That give you your heat capacity
for the gas or the
liquid or the solid.
So in fact, it's extremely
practical to make all those
measurements, and you can easily
find those values of
the heat capacities and the
delta H's tabulated for a huge
number of substances.
So this is, in fact, the
practical procedure then of
protocol for calculating
absolute entropies of all
sorts of materials at ordinary
temperatures and pressures.
Very important.
Now, one of those corollaries
to this law is that in fact
it's impossible to reduce the
temperature of any substance,
any system, all the way
to absolute, exact, no
approximations, zero Kelvin.
Because you can't quite get
down to zero Kelvin.
And there are various ways that
you can see that this
must be the case.
But here's one way to
think about it.
So, let's just write
that first.
All right, can't get quite
down to zero Kelvin.
All right, let's consider
a mole of an ideal gas.
So p is RT over V. And let's
start at T1 and V1, and now
let's bring it down to some
lower temperature, T2 in some
spontaneous process.
We'll make it adiabatic
so it's like an
irreversible expansion.
I just want to calculate what
delta S would be there in
terms of T and V.
So, well, du is T
dS minus p dV.
dS is du over T plus
p over T dV.
But we can also write du is
Cv dT in this case, right?
So that says that p over T,
that's R over V, and we can
write, dS is Cv dT over T plus
R dV over V. It's Cv, I'll
write it as d(log T) plus R
d(log V), and so delta S, Cv
log of T2 minus log of T1, if
T2 is my final temperature,
plus R log of V2 minus
log of V1, okay.
Or Cv log of T2 over T1 plus
R log of V2 over V1.
Well, what does it mean
when T2 is zero?
Well, I don't know
what it means.
This turns into negative
infinity.
So we're going to write it again
as our either evil or at
least unattainable color.
What's going to happen?
I mean you could say, well, we
can counteract it by having
this go to plus infinity,
right.
Make the volume infinite.
In other words, have the
expansion be in through an
infinite volume.
Of course that's impossible.
That would be the only
way to counteract the
divergence of this term.
In practice, you really cannot
get to absolute zero, but it
is possible to get
extremely close.
That's doable experimentally.
It's possible to get down to
some micro or nano Kelvin
temperatures, right.
In fact, our MIT physicist,
Wolfgang Ketterle, by bringing
atoms and molecules down to
extremely low temperatures,
was able to see them all reach
the very lowest possible
quantum state available
to them.
All sorts of unusual properties
emerge in that kind
of state, where the atoms and
molecules behave coherently.
You can make matter waves,
right, and see interferences
among them because of the fact
that they're all in this
lowest quantum state.
So it is possible to get
extremely low temperatures,
but never absolute zero.
Here's another way to
think about it.
You could consider what happens
to the absolute
entropy, starting at T
equals zero, right.
So we already saw that, you
know, that we can go, the
first step will go from zero to
some temperature of Cp over
T for the solid dT if we start
at zero Kelvin and warm up.
Now, already we've
got a problem.
If this initial temperature
really is zero, what happens?
This diverge, right.
Well, in fact, what that
suggests is as you approach
zero Kelvin, the heat capacity
also approaches zero.
So, does this go to infinity as
T approaches zero Kelvin?
Well, not if Cp of the solid
approaches zero as T
approaches zero Kelvin.
And in fact, we can measure Cp,
heat capacities at very
low temperatures, and what
we find is, they do.
They do go to zero as you
approach zero Kelvin.
So in fact, Cp of T approaches
zero as T
approaches zero Kelvin.
Good!
But one thing that this says is,
remember, that dT is dq at
the heat in divided by Cp.
And this is getting really,
really small.
It's going to zero
as temperature
goes to zero, right.
Which means that this
is enormous.
What it says is even the tiniest
amount the heat input
leads to a significant change
increase in the temperature.
So, this is another way of
understanding why it just
becomes impossible to lower the
temperature of a system to
absolute zero, because any kind
of contact, and I mean
any kind, like let's
say you've got the
system in some cryostat.
Of course the walls of the
cryostat aren't at zero
Kelvin, but somewhere in here
it's at zero Kelvin.
You can say, okay I won't
won't make it in
contact with the walls.
You can try, but actually light,
photons that emit from
the walls go into the sample.
You wouldn't think that heats
something up very much, and it
doesn't heat it up very
much, but we're not
talking about very much.
It does heat it up by enough
that you can't get the
absolute zero.
In other words, somehow it will
be in contact with stuff
around that is not at absolute
zero Kelvin.
And even that kind of radiative
contact is enough,
in fact, to make it not
reach absolute zero.
So the point is, one way or
another, you can easily see
that it becomes impossible to
keep pulling heat out of
something and keep it down at
the temperature that's right
there at zero, but again it's
possible to get very close.
All right, what we're going to
be able to do next time is
take what we've seen so far, and
develop the conditions for
reaching equilibrium.
So in a general sense, we'll be
able to tell which way the
processes go left unto
themselves to move toward
equilibrium.